hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
ideas running throughout Simone de
Beauvoir voluminous work the second sex
one that she introduces right at the
beginning in the introduction is the
conception and the reality is not just
abstract notion but the reality of woman
as other and she begins talking about
the very notion of writing a book on
women and how that could seem a little
strange she said a man would never get
the notion of writing a book on the
peculiar situation of the human male but
if I wish to define myself I must first
of all say I am a woman on this truth
must be based off further discussion a
man never begins by presenting himself
as an individual of a certain sex it
goes without saying that he is a man the
terms masculine and feminine are used
symmetrically only as a matter of form
so they're not opposites in the same
sense and say black and white right
where they're both on the same plane
there's there's something else going on
there and she's going to formulate this
in terms of this this general conception
of the other and she's going to talk
about how there's similarities and
differences to
other dynamics that involve the self or
the one and the other so she talks about
woman being defined not in herself but
as relative to man
she says Humanity is male man defines
woman notice man defines woman not in
herself but is relative to him she is
not regarded as an autonomous being and
that's one of the key themes that's
going to run throughout this entire
analysis there will be exceptions of
course but she's talking in the general
about how things have typically been
going and she's looking back over over
history as well now she then moves to
talking about this primordial that is
there from the beginning in humanity
differentiation that takes place and she
says the category of the other is as
primordial as consciousness itself in
the most primitive societies and the
most ancient mythologies one finds the
expression of a duality the self and the
other and she notes to that this is not
something originally tied to male and
female right it's not it originally
attached to the division of the sexes it
was not dependent upon any empirical
facts but this is what anthropologists
looking at various really we could say
historical because we have some you know
study of them possible in terms of
history historically existing societies
we find these structures emerging over
and over and over again and she says
that no group ever sets itself up as the
one without at once setting up the other
over against itself and she gives some
examples of this she says if three
travelers chance to occupy the same
compartment that's enough to make
vaguely hostile others out of all the
rest of the passengers on the train in a
small town eyes all persons not
belonging to the village or strangers
and suspect to the native of a country
all who inhabit other countries are
foreigners Jews are different for the
anti-semite Negroes are inferior for a
mayor
racists Aborigines are natives for
colonists proletarians are lower-class
for the privileged and so we see over
and over again in a variety of different
settings this other ring of one group
that you know or at least individual who
stands out is being different who
doesn't fit in how do women then come to
the other well here we're gonna start to
get to we're gonna get closer to it she
talks about this Hegelian concept of
self consciousness this is a notion that
she's taking from Hegel she says if
following Hegel we find in consciousness
itself a fundamental hostility towards
every other consciousness the subject
can be posed only in being opposed he
sets himself up as the essential as
opposed to the other the in essential
the object so if we we're not looking at
men and women or whatever other sex or
gender differentiations we want to make
if we wanted to apply this more broadly
we can talk about us and them those
people living over there in medieval
times for example residents of the next
village over might be viewed as
foreigners and you might have terrible
conflicts with them you know quite
bloody if they come over to your point
your town your point of view right they
invade your space so what is going on
here she's alluding to this Hegelian
conception of consciousness in which
self consciousness cannot exist entirely
on its own it exists through other self
consciousnesses and yet at the same time
in its primitive state it feels insecure
about that and it wants to bind the
other self consciousness who wants to
place itself above it it wants to turn
that other self-consciousness into an
object what a strange kind of object an
object which can reflect the subject
back to it the self back to it and
provide it with what Hegel calls
recognition in German on air Kenan and
this is indeed at the heart of what de
Beauvoir is talking about women for
centuries for millennia
even up till the present in many cases
are placed in a situation where they're
there primarily to function as an object
to reflect back to men something else
that allows them the men to feel assured
of themselves she goes on and she says
the other consciousness the other ego
sets up a reciprocal claim when I'm
doing this if I'm self consciousness and
I'm encountering another
self-consciousness and trying to impose
the structures I would like upon it
whether these be political meaning you
know expectations they're also doing the
same thing to me
so she gives a great example the native
traveling abroad is shocked to find
himself in turn regarded as a stranger
by the natives of neighboring countries
and she says that Wars festivals trading
treaties and contests among tribes
nation and classes tend to deprive the
concept other of its absolute sense and
make manifest its relativity so we're
forced to realize that we also can be
other right and she talks about a
reciprocity there now then she raises an
important question why does this not
happen in the case of women for example
why you know when men give their version
of events about what's going on and how
the household is structured or what's
going on with the family and then women
say no no that's not really the case why
are they ignored why are they who pood
why are they pushed off to the side why
isn't there sort of a dynamic in which
some sort of equality gets worked out
where the men say oh I hadn't thought of
things that way
I guess I really need to see myself
through your eyes not just my imposition
of what your eyes should reflect back to
me why doesn't that happen so here she
she says well here we go how is it this
reciprocity has not been recognized
between the sexes that one of the
contrasting terms is set up as the sole
essential denying any relativity in
regard to its correlative and
finding the latter as pure other
nonnatus pute male serenity no subject
will readily volunteer to become the
object in essential it's not the other
who in defining himself as the other
establishes the one the other is posed
as such by the one in defining himself
as the one but if the other is not to
regain the status of being the one he
must be submissive enough to accept this
alien point of view and this is a high
Galilean conception again alienation
being made foreign to yourself being
made other to yourself why do women
accept this she asks as a woman now of
course there's exceptions throughout
history but those exceptions don't prove
the rule so he or she turns to looking
at this other ring or Altera tee if you
will and how it plays out in other
domains so she says there are other
cases in which a certain category has
been able to dominate another completely
for a time very often this privilege
depends on inequality of numbers the
majority imposes its rule upon the
minority or persecutes it and we might
add to that as well having an advantage
and technology we could think of the
Guns Germs and Steel notion as well you
know coming from that popular book one
group quite often throughout history is
able to impose itself not just
politically but in terms of how it makes
sense of the meaning of different human
beings it's able to impose those
structures upon another so she gives
examples here of for example African
Americans in in America right
particularly in the south at the time
that she's writing civil rights struggle
is still you know well underway and
there's been a whole you know history of
slavery and then the failed
reconstruction and terrorism and you
know voter suppression and all sorts of
other things going on in the south as
well she gives another example of the
Jews throughout the entire
history that they have really once
they're dispersed from from their their
land and she says women are not a
minority though there's as many women as
there are men on earth so what's going
on there is it really the case that men
is a majority impose their will on women
or they had some sort of technological
advantage that they imposed on women
they actually live in the same
households so that doesn't make sense
what else she says again these two
groups concerned have often been
originally independent they may have
been formerly aware of each other's
existence so you know before different
groups encountered each other and we
don't have to go to you know modern
conceptions of race which are just
hodgepodge as it is let's think about
you know people in ancient times you
know at one time the Egyptians were a
major civilization and they had not as
of yet encountered say the Persians
Persians eventually conquered Egypt many
other people had conquered Egypt by that
time as well and you could say well
these groups didn't know about each
other but once they do then one imposes
its will upon the other that's not the
case for women and men women and men
have always existed that's the nature of
the race right we are creatures that
reproduce that that continue on this
this race that we are intend tracking in
terms of race as the entire human race
by biological reproduction so that's not
really that good of a parallel right
she then talks about women and the
proletariat the working class right she
says that there's a parallel drawn
between women and the proletariat that's
that's valid in that neither ever formed
a minority or a separate collective unit
of humankind and instead of a single
historical event it's in both cases of
historical development that explains
their status as a class and accounts for
the membership of particular individuals
in that class but there's a vital
difference here proletariat's have not
always existed whereas there have always
been women you could you might say well
what haven't people always done work
yes but the modern proletariat the
working class as it's formed through
industrial society and and and you know
the way in which it arises that's a
historical recent development women have
always been around and so you know she's
going to point out women have been
subordinated throughout all of recorded
history that's different than these
other others she goes on and she also
says well what's the what's the
difference here
you know another main difference is that
a condition brought about it's a certain
time can be abolished at some other time
as for example the revolutions in Haiti
right have proved but women haven't done
this she says women do not say we
accepted some Congress of feminists or
similar formal demonstration men say
women and women use the same word in
referring to themselves they do not
authentically assume a subjective
attitude so they they don't engage in in
revolution and of course she's writing
this long before many of the
developments of our own time so we might
consider this necessary to revise but
she points out an important dimension of
this she says the reason why that has
been the case is that women lack
concrete means for organizing themselves
into a unit into some sort of we or the
one or the self which can stand face to
face with the correlative unit here she
makes some pretty startling claims they
have no past no history no religion of
their own they have no such solidarity
of work and interest as that of the
proletariat they are not even
promiscuously herded together in the way
that creates community feeling among
african-americans ghetto Jews workers of
South Denis or the factory hands over
know they live dispersed throughout the
mails attached through residents
housework and economic condition and
social standing to certain men fathers
or husbands more firmly than they are to
other women if they belong to the
bourgeoisie they feel solidarity with
men of that class not with proletarian
women and she goes on and on about that
saying that up until the time that she's
talking about women have in fact not
been organizing themselves in such a way
as there was something like a general
women's consciousness that could stand
over and against male consciousness and
then demand to be recognized in this
Hegelian sense so another way that she
expresses this is to say that the basic
trait of women is to be other in a
totality now that the totality is not a
differentiating trait every self and
other thing forms a certain totality but
it's a totality in which the two
components she says are necessary to
each other how are they necessary to
each other well in part through our
biological relation to each other right
through reproduction but it's made so in
other ways as well that are going to go
much further into to culture and she
says that master and slave are also
united by a reciprocal need in this case
economic which does not liberate the
slave in the relation of master to slave
the master does not make a point of the
need that he has for the other he has in
his grasp the power of satisfying this
need through his own action whereas the
slave in his dependent condition is hope
and fear is quite conscious of the need
he has for his master and she goes on
and she says now women has always been
man's dependent if not his slave the two
sexes have never shared the world in
equality so there's always been some
measure of inequality she says even when
her rights are legally recognized in the
abstract long-standing custom prevents
their full expression in the mores so
there could be a formal equality but a
actual or material inequality another
thing that she talks about is the
structure of society and she frames this
in terms of a certain kind of deal she
says that women now are able to break
into the workplace are able to break
into the culture are able to you know
take on some of what men held as an
exclusive privilege or or domain but in
doing so they have to agree to a lot of
parts of that deal and part of that is
being the other in the sense that we're
talking about she points out to decline
to be the other to refuse to be a party
to the deal this would be for women to
renounce all the advantages conferred
upon them by their alliance with the
superior caste so the structure of
society not just that there's you know
inequality right here right now it's
there's a structure that continues to
generate that inequality by requiring
buy-in by women to that very structure
she then also talks about a certain
complicity going on as well she says
that here we go it's an easy road on
that one avoids the strain involved in
undertaking an authentic existence when
man makes of women the other he may then
expect her to manifest deep-seated
tendencies towards complicity woman may
fail to lay claim to the status of
subject because she lacks definite
resources because she feels the
necessary bond that ties her to man
regardless of reciprocity and because
she is often well pleased with her role
as other and this is where the
existentialism of de Beauvoir is coming
out and being manifested we we all have
choices though those choices that we
make they're not always within
frameworks that we would choose but we
do have choices and one of those choices
one of those options is that of
complicity and therefore sort of
ratifying the status of this fundamental
division between men and women making
men the self or the one and women the
other
you